name is Andre Holmes graduated 2011 and
I play for the Buffalo Bills my time at
Hillsdale was it's pretty hard to start
off with as far as academic wise but one
of the things that helped out was just
having great teammates great people at
the school that you know helped me out
it's kind of like a true testament
exactly what Hillsdale College is you
know everyone's trying to help each
other and everyone really cares about
each other because it's such a
tight-knit group
coach Otterbein who's great coach and
you know he has a great smile and
everything but when you're player you
don't really see that smile as much you
know he's the guy that wants to make
sure that you're doing the right things
and it really cares about how his
players grow he was hard on me and hard
on other teammates but that's just you
know the father away from home you see
the teddy bear you know once you
graduate you see how much he really does
care about his players as far as
football goes just being able to go to
playoffs for the first time I think
that's just like 1980 84 something like
that that's like my what I've been doing
all throughout my career is just
breaking you know slumps and going to
playoffs and it's a lot of fun doing me
I'm gonna do that I think the work ethic
comes from not wanting to fail when I
fail I feel like I'm feeling everybody
close to me if I can control something
then I better give it the best effort
that I can give because if I don't then
I'll just look back at it with regret
really the the records just kind of King
which is playing the game you know I
wasn't out there like thinking about
whether or not I could break a record or
all the records right there for the
taking I was just doing was just playing
the game and if you start looking at
records and everything then you know
that's when you don't get the record now
what's motivating me is really like the
love of the game all of a sudden like
two years ago my intelligence and IQ as
far as football like just went through
the roof and like finally I just got it
and all three phases of the game offense
defense busting like I just understood
everything it allowed the game to slow
down and allow the game to be fun again
when we would do our offseason program
at Hillsdale we would do our stretch
line some of our drills in the hallway
and you just look at the wall of fame
over and over especially at Hillsdale to
be in the Hall of Fame is amazing
because of all the tradition and I'm
very thankful for that too to be in the
hall
[Music]
[Applause]
you